it happened just hours before the
opening of the Turkish Parliament the
attackers arrived at the ministry of
interior building in Ankara in a Light
commercial
vehicle one of them carrying a
russian-made rocket launcher got out of
the car and headed directly towards the
building's guard Tower the other with an
americanmade M4 assault rifle used the
car as a
shield thanks to the determination of
our sec forces the moment that the
attackers got out of their vehicle they
started to shoot at them one of the
terrorists detonated a suicide vest and
the other was shot in the head without
having an opportunity to detonate
himself authorities say the weapons used
in this attack were provided by the US
and Russia to the Kurdish ypg armed
group in Syria an American Ally in the
fight against
isil MPS inside Parliament were
returning to work after their summer
break where they're expected to ratify
Sweden's entry into NATO after the
opening of the Turkish Parliament there
will be a voting about the participation
or acceptance of Sweden to Nato and
there are terrorist organizations in
Sweden being supported by Sweden and
they are against the participation of
Sweden to Nato as well so that might be
a kind of incident uh which is trying to
affect the decision of the Turkish
parliamentary as well police say the
attacker stole the vehicle and killed
its driver in kaiseri a city 260 kilm
southeast of Ankara before launching the
attack the government has carried out a
series of operations targeting armed
groups recently in claiming
responsibility Kurdish Fighters with the
pkk armed groups said the attack was a
warning to authorities to stand down
however the president and his security
minister say the operations will
continue until the last fighter is
driven out of turkey cam KOLO Al jazer
anara make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer